welcome to this 15-minute game playing
yeah badass badass from from from
Finland let's see nice SI not so bad as
okay let's see here in Queens gambit
maybe with d5 form what is he aiming for
taking some time I can go back to a
default Penang but why not this is quite
a nice move order device so that after
Bishop b4 endings of Indian style you
have various ways to play without deform
this is one of them quick Quincy to our
queen bee three which is similar to the
classical new minion with Quincy too but
you haven't played deform so some
sources of counter player not possible
here
yeah black here we are Castle a three
castles a 3ds are normal moves sometimes
black can even play Bishop f5 and such a
such a position not here yeah what I've
never sure there are two basic ways for
white to develop with g3 or with e3 and
I'm not really never sure what sorts
right I like to play be four that's
clear so I start with that
yeah and I'll go with you 3 i'm really
unsure there are games with with both
setups and i'm never sure about the
subtle points what exactly should be
preferred in what case so just just do
this
yeah just developing Bishop b2 and
German yeah deform or d3 I guess deform
maybe I should play d4 really before he
gets an e5 that's black want to play a
five year as you recognize probably I'm
not so familiar with the structure I
have played this kind of Knight f3 see
for openings quite a lot but this
specific line I didn't really get on the
board much and never studied it deeply
if i take here isn't this good structure
in any case be take see luke t 1 yeah
maybe he can go d phi but let's say it
takes with the deep on this should be
quite nice good play on the d far rock
g1 or Bishop b2 first not sure yeah
let's let's not spend time in ambition
between it's maybe not a big difference
yeah not sure should I play be five or
not keeping the Queen side keeping the
queenside closed and probably I think I
should do that just gaining the space am
sometimes black can take play a five and
win the c5 square for the night not not
sure I want that when this type of
position is certainly slightly favorable
for white but it's still symmetrical so
not not so easy to make any any big
headway okay I want to gain space that
sets clear the main point is spatium
yeah that's always a tricky move a
tricky move it looks like a move that
helps like but I'm not sure I'm not sure
it also we can serve some squares let's
see yeah probably work T 1 it Ricans f5
and d5 this is what I me and let's see
it's very tough to maybe I should have
played 85 actually if I first yeah I
should have played 85 maybe he's giving
me the chance to still do it after a
five phone I have gained really lots of
lots of space I will also play a six if
if give me the chance yeah we r oq one
was a bit superficial not a good idea to
play that quickly a five was probably
more consistent
okay but let's see I don't really think
he has something terribly great
available him for example I don't think
that that efore is is helping him much
this would open up this long diagonal
with the Queen Bishop battery and 94
Quincy to us yeah I go here anyway it's
not probably not leading to much the
night is is only for great but what is
it doing after that maybe f6 yeah like f
696 this could be an IBM but f6 I have
Bishop d3 right this wins outright I
know not outright you can play a five
not a great move but possible
and yeah I really don't think that's not
you for help so much maybe you should
think about all 96 moon this also may be
nigh g but it's also not helping it's
not easy to make any progress here in
general black would like to play
something like for like f6 maybe you
should I just just drop back it's maybe
not not a bad move okay um I play five
now get this get this in while still
possible
what would be very funny if I could get
in something like a six Bishop to a
eight and then efore at some point with
a bishop on 8 a-8 totally totally killed
but the prod he probably won't happen
it's still a threat that you can work
with um yeah if you should take I mean
very unlikely but possible I think I
just played Bishop c3m and John get it
back conveniently with the rukon a 50 s
bishop on a five so yeah this is what I
had expected in a way so to see three
again maybe keeping the pressure on e5
so that he cannot easily move the night
from this heavens this is a lot this is
a slight problem really that this a 5 a
move is also creating a target he also
always must must protect you five and
that's not not so easy it's somewhat
it's a somewhat on ammonius position you
would really like to play f6 keeper if I
protected reliably maybe you should
think of something like an age 69 h7
night fa def six this is kind of this
kind of thing ok yeah I'm wondering a
bit if if i should play really this a 6
space gainer or open up the file opening
up the FR is certainly also making lots
of sense
hmm
I'm head almost eight minutes on the
clock in a game this is really unheard
of but I played it rather quickly for
once not worrying too much about each
each moves koala team just being quick
okay this is what I want to do anyway
the knight on f3 it is always attacking
this e for pond true but 92 now ask the
bishop a very important question we are
you going and with the Buddha subsequent
f3 I am can really blunt the long
diagonal and prepare further space gains
okay wondering yeah this is what I
wanted to do anyway so let's play it
Bishop f3 was also interesting actually
maybe I should have thought about this
briefly as a bishop lending on c6 can
also be tricky if I'm but okay f3 is
some very normal moves and the structure
controlling important squares on e4 I
have f4 that's very nice and yeah let's
see what to do here there's even the
possibility to to gain space with the g4
at a later stage okay I'll start with
this this complete bind and then I'd
everyone back
my long-term plan is G for Nigeria and
expand on the King side as well
yeah G for now I can't even do that
efore that's f4 I have this made on g7
so maybe do that come on let's keep the
pressure on the clock pressure I me know
if I now play a for you cannot take
because of the the maid f4f 6 f5 alright
so it's a huge space gain but not so
sure that that it's helping me this is
also quite nice just here and keeping
this idea open nitey 46 and Bishop d3
app Bishop d3 now is also nice he has
got 95 though should I go age for maybe
fyf if I have f4 let's do that looks
nice and and now Bishop to d3 okay
Bishop d3 there is there is there is a
form may be mapped I can take bath
tonight 96 though this is a this is
tricky yeah maybe actually I can do that
why not efore 94 is really really not
terrible OE 494 Bishop g4 I ur F ear ook
takes and something like that could be
possible okay it did not happen
yeah he's doubling on the DL of course i
would like to simply trade trade the and
trade or all rooks and queens okay i
don't mind to just trade thread this off
a minor piece and gamma sir is very nice
of course with this big space big space
advantage and i have constant ideas of
sacrifices against b6 and c5 p.m. with
this huge space it's very very tough to
defend if at all possible yes but i have
f4 right or is there a big idea g5 well
let's let's play it first I mean no
alternative anyway
yeah unless he has some some big big
point him the cell was not helping him
okay at the end Queen d7 oh nice no I
it's mostly a trade right g4 fought for
a phone if I take you for him here maybe
it's got Queen to the one which could be
a problem
the should be you for Queen D 1 yeah but
there is Quincy one okay and then I
really prefer to take with the bishop
attending queen d 3
yeah this is student excellent endgame
Queen d1 Quincy one basically forces the
trade you can go to be three but this is
not really doing anything great okay I'm
just Queen d3 right getting Queen's
office is excellent yeah now the big big
point is nightie for end and all the way
to the queenside setting up p sacrifices
night can I take already night see 5bne
KX b6 b6 and I'm simultaneously
threatening b7 and taking isn't this
already a win
probably is 95 takes b6 threatening to
take on 87 now Bishop c8 there is b7
winning I can take a better than half
Bishop c5 okay this is a win come on IB
697 actually takes on a seven-night b6
okay but Bishop e3 it's probably still
winning but this wasn't the cleanest
solution pretty sure forgot about Knight
b6 unfortunately
all right okay must take it cannot
defend it if he doesn't take it yeah he
should have done so i mean this is this
is not really easy he taking be 697 was
probably still okay probably be 697
takes Knight b6 probably okay now c5
should should do the trick
take he and take g6 black resigns yeah I
think this was a miscalculation 95 oh it
is winning okay it is winning okay um I
wasn't yeah thanks I wasn't sure here if
I take be 697 Teague's I bishop efore
Yap Bishop before okay this is in fact
quite quite convincing I was only
thinking about this year it's fitz also
winning him it's also winning it's just
too much this is the computers line yeah
what's advantageous is Tudor great i
mean this is also a terrible PCM i just
get f5 king d for Bishop t65 it's just
all rolling okay so 95 one after all I
was just a bit shocked that I had
overlooked night be six to eight yeah
around here this this was a very
one-sided position with the with this in
black has absolutely no counter play can
only think about um yeah how to somehow
keep it together but just very
unattractive position Bishop d3 was well
again this is now gets gets really ugly
yeah this this is really lost it's too
much there are multiple piece Accra
files also note that's not only see five
but also be six bike and sacrifice and
sometimes there's even things like that
coming
taking b6 and I'm breaking through this
is the the problem with this kind of
advanced upon formation you always have
those p sacrifices that set the pawns in
motion at the end it's it's it's all the
way a solid position from like but you
can never do much I think a five would
have been better really for me and here
I I took the chance to again play it and
what he did is he didn't do anything
active ever just just basically state
and didn't do anything great here also
efore came into consideration efore
93-95 but I didn't want that yet I think
I think g4 was okay but Sir it's a good
way to improve um yeah he never really
has this move because of F form which
keeps everything nicely together yeah
nice positional game I liked it I hope
you did as well thanks for watching